the health secretary sajid javis says
that the app is being modified today
so fewer people will be required to
self-isolate um this is to ease the
pressures of what's being done the
pandemic
let's head to westminster and get
reaction our chief political
correspondent john craig
has been looking through what details we
have so far john
this is a big climb down because of
course there's been fury at the number
of people
who've been forced to isolate because
they're being pinged
because they've been told they've come
into contact with someone who tested
positive
the big change is this currently
for people who input a positive test but
are asymptomatic
the app looks for close contacts five
days prior to a positive test this will
be updated based on public health advice
to look back at contacts two days to a
positive test
so the idea is that far fewer people
will be pinged
the government announcement says fewer
contacts will be notified
uh it says that mr
javid has said that we want to reduce
the disruption that
self-isolation can cause for people and
businesses while ensuring we're
protecting those most at risk from the
virus
this uh update to the app will ensure
we're striking the right balance same
phrase as we heard from the prime
minister a moment ago
he said it's so important that people
isolate when asked to do so to mr javid
in order to stop the spread of the virus
and protect their communities
nowhere in this announcement does it
acknowledge that a lot of people are
switching it off
uh but uh we are all being urged uh to
uh
to uh to carry on using the app uh a few
moments ago
uh dr jenny harris now she's the chief
executive of the uk
health security agency i said this
announcing this very important and
significant change
so we've had some really good uh new
research back recently
uh more than two thousand cases of covid
are being prevented each day by the use
of the app and we know that
forty percent of the eligible population
are still continuing to use it
and we want people to have confidence
that it's helping them
to protect those nearest to them what we
are doing in this new context
of opening up is to try and get the
balance right between the public
health advice and the way people are
living their lives and the social
and economic factors affecting them and
so we are altering the logic of the app
which will mean that fewer contacts will
be contacted
will be advised to isolate and that is
because we will only be contacting those
at higher risk
where they have had very close contact
uh in the most infectious period
of the positive case if this change how
worried would you be that people would
have
deleted the app in greater numbers or
turned off contact tracing given that so
many people
well i think people need to understand
they've been pinged because we have a
pandemic
and it is actually helping them well we
really want to get
across that the app is a friend it's not
a foe
if you're advised to self isolate if
you're advised you're a close contact
then you know you're at higher risk of
passing infection onto others
but we do want people to continue to
have confidence
and we know that if people use it we'll
continue
sorry i think yeah sorry sorry
a little glitch there but uh the key
point is that uh jenny harris there was
talking about
uh people having confidence in the app
clearly the government is concerned that
people have been losing
confidence as thousands upon thousands
of people have been pinged
uh people in whole industries are facing
chronic staffing shortages
and uh there was a real uh anger amongst
bosses amongst mps
about the number of people being pinged
so just to recap finally
the key change is this currently
for people who input a positive test but
are asymptomatic
the app looks at close context five days
to a prior to a positive test this will
be updated based on public health advice
to look back at context
contacts two days prior to a
positive test this is a big climb down
by the government
and by public health england as a result
of the anger
of the so-called pandemic